countries we like to suffer if there is
no suffering there's something wrong
curl it up
i don't think anywhere else has this
after a while
cool working forward
this is the second video of a two-part
series about
kiev i would say that air quality here
kills way more people than kovid ever
will
it's not cool that the city officials
the mayor the government here cannot
uh figure out some emission controls
because
what i didn't notice until about after
year one and then i started getting
headaches
the mayor can't be unaware of that if he
travels into europe into germany
uh the president's well traveled it's
like come on guys fix that [ __ ]
it's not cool to put that on your
population
and there are many days here you just
you just don't want to go out into it
and a lot of people from here don't even
notice i mean you don't notice
unless you uh have something else really
to compare it to
most of what most of the people that
have like this huge wealth they have a
lot of money
they usually come from very uh poor
childhood and they basically
overcompensated
oh so that's why okay guys here we are
yvonne in the mix yvonne from levive
yeah yeah it was like
old work well if anyone's watching all
the videos you might recognize
um but for those that don't yvonne is
going to tell us about the
golodamir
ivan's going to tell us about the
holomore yes
which the the basic understanding i have
is
it was an event that happened in 1932 to
famine in ukraine three to 12 million
people that died yeah but why
because the basically the communist
government didn't want
this uh as they called them kulaks this
wealthy
uh willis people they didn't want them
to become
independent and they were actually on
their way to become independent because
they were able to provide for themselves
they were
raising crops and having small farms and
ranches so
uh it was like the campaign was
basically in order to destroy these
small uh
households okay you know to basically
take everything away from them
so these people were forming their own
businesses making money yeah yeah they
were
self-sufficient yeah absolutely
absolutely so we're
the central authority out of ukraine or
out of uh moscow um
do you know out of my of course the main
orders were coming out of moscow but
generally there were people from uh
ukraine that were following those orders
and
they were coming to these people and
taking their food any
everything they had basically this is
the world war ii memorial right
yeah this okay and then uh
is that one over there okay let's go
over there and uh basically
uh the idea also was to um
create this like to break them mentally
psychologically also because they were
uh they were suffering from starvation
obviously but
as well when you live in this kind of
situation and you see
other people dying and eating each other
it's like it's crazy
so the idea was also to break them down
to break their spirit completely right
and so when i
um when people ask me from from the u.s
or from other countries what's it like
with the pandemic in ukraine right now
with corona and i'm like i don't really
feel like anyone's
too worried because you guys have had
the holodomor
you've had stalin you've had
revolutions banking crisis all these
things that have happened in
actual recent memory uh where
something like this pandemic is like
like a mosquito bite
yeah that's what it feels like
especially after my done in 2013
well to be honest with you we became
kind of tough as a boot
after a while so yeah so
i mean well you guys you guys did what
belarus is trying to do right now
but they have pretty they have different
situations
let's go through here check this out
yeah they have a
they have a tough mountain to climb for
sure we like to suffer
yeah so we want to repeat this oh you
can say it man go for it
i mean yeah if you you might have
noticed that we like to suffer it's like
it's depicted basically in everything
it's like if
there is no suffering there's something
wrong no no pain no gain
yeah that's exactly all right so here's
the start of the memorial and i was
asking yvonne why
the uh the texture here is so rough
and now that was the answer you like to
share no comfort walking to the memorial
makes sense though it's not a
comfortable event yes like reminds you
of
the at least a little bit like you
having this little moment of discomfort
it reminds you of the
rough past that we had to go through so
i was saying and this is just from my
outside perspective
you obviously have a closer ear to the
ground than i do
but uh ukraine right now the young
people
are like shooting towards newness
in the sense they're experimenting
they're trying different things you see
a white guy
making indian food you see all these new
restaurants new concepts
and i was my theory is because nobody
wants to go back to soviet times
the youth right and you're only looking
this way
whereas many european countries like i
was just in italy
it's like you don't see the changes
there
that you see here which is super
interesting it's a much wealthier
country but they're like they have their
pasta they've done forever and that's
not going to change right
yeah which is cool that's what i like
about italy like it's
it's such a great experience together
but there i don't feel like there's
much newness as much newness is here
which is really interesting yeah exactly
because we're very new to this taste of
freedom you know and
it's like very fresh for us so it's like
very new experience
so that's why we're trying to taste it
we're trying to experiment and we're
basically we're enjoying ourselves right
now you're enjoying yourself yes
as you can see right now especially if
you're in this yeah yeah i mean
okay let's let's this this is do you
know what this simplifies
can we oh we can't go past here
i'm a millennial i'm allowed to not know
yeah there it is that's really
interesting
so in your youth in your schooling was
this
this history really drilled into you um
we
uh that's the funny thing actually
because during that time
we had uh different presidents and one
of those presidents as you remember was
yanakovich and he was like pro-russians
yeah he didn't want this uh history to
be
remembered let's say and the his
government didn't want to
so when you were growing up you didn't
you weren't talking yeah no i knew i
knew about it because my grandmother
told me a lot
about it when i was a little kid like a
lot i spent
all those uh notorious long winters
in the village with her and she told me
a lot about the
hunger in 1932-33 and also after
the world war ii 1947
because she experienced this very those
are bigger deaths in the holocaust i
think
yeah i don't know the exact numbers are
going to look like that but i think that
it's like up there right yeah
[Music]
so
stay in your grave
if i want to avoid any turmoil yeah what
kind of turmoil any
any like for this at this point in time
in history like this is the the safest
place i think
at least it seems to me
[Music]
you think it's the same
pedro park this is an island of the
dining
room river yeah and it's got i've been
here only once before it's got like a
fun fair feel
right yeah what's your what's your
history with this place
was this way like it's the history of
the smell of
piss and vomit
that's my history but there are beaches
here we're gonna check out the beach
yeah yeah
yvonne did you ever partake in this
beach scene yeah when i used to be a
little
stupid and i didn't didn't care much
about hygiene and stuff
but you don't trust the water it looks
cool but that water i would not be
jumping in
because one of the tributaries comes
from chernobyl at chernobyl river yes
awesome
even take out the chernobyl it's like
still dirty it's like nobody gives a
[ __ ] about cleaning this water
city officials or the government just
has no interest in ecology
like zero like it's like air quality
clean itself
yeah i mean it looks so cool though
imagine if that was
but clean water the funny part is like
we already have the immune system to
tolerate this kind of dirty water
it's in your dna all right there's this
gym down here
a very famous famous outdoor gym
i'm not a gym guy at all but it's worth
it
we're checking it out i actually came
here a few weeks ago to check it out
quite entertaining i have never been
there but it seems to me like the us is
like a huge eco
chamber yeah like it needs fresh air
it is well said it does need fresh air
with that stuff
and we're talking about cancer culture
and how people can get
cut out immediately for saying the wrong
thing
okay here we are this is where people
get
ripped and keep it's a free gym right
man
it's like it's a certain lighting and
it's certain weather it seems like a
scene
from the horror movie it's great though
this is awesome
do a little swim come out and
curl it up
[Music]
this is cool though i don't think
anywhere else has this yeah yeah look
it's just everything's like um
just tractor parts different welds
homemade looks like they could uh
this gym could withstand a chernobyl two
more nuclear
winter it'll be fine
when it's overcast and when there is
foggy there is fog
does the bar bend because the weight is
so much is that right
that can't be right well i don't know no
this is thick this is thick steel
yeah it's just made that way like very
well prepared
in terms of like basically the way it
was like 20 or
30 years ago this is very ussr
to use this kind of uh cover for this
like when something gets bad
rather when the surface gets bad we
usually yes at this point oh it's
like some some tablecloths very ussr you
you'll never gonna find this anywhere
else in the world so what do you miss
about the ussr
nothing i haven't been there i don't
want to go there all right zero zero
this is cool this is cool this is unique
it's like a nice like
museum it's like a museum it's nice to
visit but no way
you know no way in the world i would
love to get begged there and
in the subconscious so yeah i think i
mean i'm 28 and i still have this
remnants of this
all bad habits that i know is like very
ussr
in terms of some kind of inner blocks
and maybe
mental blocks and all this like very
what's alone and what's not allowed
what's appropriate what's not
appropriate it's like there is still
like very deeply
deep the [ __ ] down it's ingrained
in our like the generation of my brother
who's 18 right now they
uh fortunately they don't have it
what's in these places it's like for
garages like for
cars and it's like this is it's
also the very significant
these are uh garage and this is like
also very like
very specific like ussr culture because
uh
men tend to have garage but not
necessarily every of them have a car
and they just love this place to hang
out with man cave drink beer
talk about women go have this like
locker room talk
like it's very also like very in like
part of
a significant part of our culture of
previous generations right
all right guys we're gonna go out to a
beach here i'm gonna show you a beach
and uh wrap it up wrap it up at a very
cool
new location here in kiev uh quite
impressive
i gotta say in the city limits we have
an island here i think this is true
hanif island
a lot of pass a lot of cool places to
hang out there
volleyball why don't you hang out over
here it's pretty cool
i gotta say you guys are pretty good at
uh hanging out together
having a good time not over stressing am
i right on that not over stressing
you know it's like funny it's like a
paradox we are able to
over stress while hanging out but we
also managed to enjoy being stressed
about some kind of [ __ ] some kind of
minutiae
so it's like a part of our recreation
process i would say
and what's this in here like a beach
club
let's try to see what is it i can't even
see what the camera's saying
and we are starting to wake up to the
fact that we have to take care of of our
environment at least on some level right
at least on saturday
and i'm still i'm very much optimistic
about because
there were there was no there was there
was no awareness in soviets yes right
yeah
we want to elect the weird the sportsman
the comedian guy
and just to see what happened what's
gonna happen you just were curious
i think i think universally people are
so sick of politicians
yeah like even if it might like even if
there's a possibility for
everything to go to hell in a hand
basket we're like let's
[ __ ] checklist look at that ferrari
chilling out there
yeah jesus oh here you have like a
pretty stereotypical picture
explain it for me what's the
stereotypical that's what i was
talking about in the beginning about the
people who were pretty poor
[Music]
what open krito
you want me to translate for you bro i'm
[Music]
this is what i mean about the city of
contrast we have that gym
just in there in the trees yeah then the
ferrari
and the beach club very very much
mixed up brother that's what i love
about it it's all over the place you
can't
you can't put a finger on it you can't
label it
[Music]
photo zone
looks like we got a beach lounge scene
[Music]
i'm sure there's a i'm sure this is a
raging nightlife here huh
yeah it is true
[Music]
all right that's enough
interesting did you know this existed
there are several places like this
guys i haven't gone into the real bad
neighborhoods again there are no real
super bad dangerous neighborhoods during
the day
i did a video on these haven't gone to
the outskirts where they're the decrepit
apartment blocks but i'm trying to and i
think i'm conveying a lot of this
the contrast here
so how do you feel oh yeah i love this
stuff
what are you getting my nose here
he knows he's crap like he's a very
experienced guy
see the stuff with experiences like this
is you can't
you can't even recre you can't recreate
you know they organically start
and then become established and if you
ever tried to make this
you know by design it just wouldn't work
that's what the city has
these old guys getting into it
people found this place
[Music]
russia these are like real holes from
the
gun from the bullet holes bullet holes
yes from 1917.
ah i yes i guess my 1917
i i might be wrong about the year but
yes these are real
all right guys we've done quite a job
revenge uh
revamping it renovating it and then this
place over here
key food market we're just gonna step in
there for a second
i'll show you what that's all about it's
quite cool
this i gotta say is impressive this
whole scene
it goes on for a waze too right all the
way down there
it's pretty beautiful and atmospheric
but in like in these small isles
right right right not everywhere but
when like you might stones like this
let's go in the key food mark
[Music]
this place is pumping
great selection here all different
restaurants from
i think these are all restaurants in the
city right most of these places
i know dogs and tails is so here we have
restaurants uh in the city but they have
small restaurants here
we've got at least 20 or so
very cool atmosphere this opened up in
like the last year
all right guys hope you felt it today
the contrast of keith
just so you know that's a very small
scratch of the surface
of this city there are a lot of stories
a lot of narratives happening
and uh well i was just a bit so hope you
felt that
until the next one
these old guys getting into it